stop hiring the wrong people everybody
welcome to the book update video it's a
gloomy day here in Toronto the the
weather has given me a big headache and
so I apologize if I'm not a hundred
percent on my game today but the show
must go on must give you guys an update
and answer your questions and today I
want to talk about hiring the wrong
people I had a call earlier this morning
with an entrepreneur who has three
people on his team and he feels like all
three of them of the wrong people he
feels like they don't do work unless
he's on top of them and micromanaging he
feels like they just do the bare minimum
sometimes not even that and he's
frustrated because he feels like he's
giving up opportunities for growth and
he wants to do something big and he
can't do it alone and he just feels like
he has the wrong people around him it's
a super common issue and I think one you
know it may be on you you may be the
problem that you want to make sure
you're giving people opportunities
you're treating them like human beings
like people you have growth for them you
know you care about their development
it's not just do these five things get
that done by tomorrow and treating it
like a piece of meat but I think a lot
of us also settle for the wrong people
you know you're just looking for
somebody to help you program a website
so you find someone has the skills who
you're maybe not compatible with you
don't share the same values with who you
know you don't have the ability to grow
something big with them and if you hire
the wrong people this is an expression
that good is the enemy of great if you
hire people who are just good you're
never going to fire them because they're
just good they're doing their job
they're okay but they're not great and
that's what you need you need the great
and how this relates to my book I'm
really fortunate to have an amazing team
helping me with my book and I'm excited
today to go in and write and edit
because well one of the reasons is one
of the guys on my team j reyez has a
surprise for me he did something to
chapter six that is a big surprise I
don't know what he did Jen saw it she's
all excited about it and so I'm going to
be able to go in today and check out
what happened and that's good right
that's what you want you want people on
team who are going to give you surprises
we're going to go above and beyond we're
going to do things that that help you
beyond the task that you specifically
gave them right and I think even about
this YouTube channel you guys are
watching Ivan does a lot of the research
for it this involved in the comments my
wife Nina's involved in the comments
Christina does a lot of the video
editing her and her husband do it
together and they're always throwing in
little surprises right they add sound
effects and b-roll and cuts and a lot of
things that I may not have thought of
and I really appreciate that and you
need those kinds of people to help you
grow your team so stop hiring the wrong
people stop settling for good and bring
on a team of people that you can
actually grow something special with so
that's the message of the day now let's
get to your questions alright first stop
Tamara weeks long time loyal viewer has
a question for me you get to go first
hammer your motivation works faster than
a bullet love it thank you I appreciate
that great video are there any copyright
laws with book titles that would prevent
you from getting too close to the same
book title as the one you mentioned so
this is an interesting question number
one you cannot copy write a book title
you can't copyright a book title you
can't copyright a movie named you can't
copyright a song name copyrights are
there to protect longer works and so no
there's no worry for me I'm about having
somebody else's name from a cop right
perspective you can though trademark a
name but usually trademarks are only
applicable to series it's very rare to
have a trademark for one book it's more
for a series so as an example Lord of
the Rings is a series or the four hour
series from Tim Ferriss for our body for
a work week for our what's the other one
chef he could trade mark that for our
but otherwise it was just a single title
you don't really have protection over a
name Pete 4725 question i'm experiencing
the dead computer issue i have a plan B
so I'm still putting out content until I
get a new one what is the time you
experience this issue and how did you
handle it did you have a plan B I think
as entrepreneurs we constantly
especially the beginning are
under-resourced like a computer is one
resource you constantly don't have
enough resources to do what you need to
do and that's part of being an
entrepreneur because you're limited in
your
resources but unlimited in your
resourcefulness and so I've never had
that issue in terms of a computer I just
thought you I did I think back to when I
really needed a laptop when I was
starting my business I didn't want to go
out and buy a laptop because I don't
believe in spending money till I'm
making money and I ended up connecting
with an organization that was helping
young people around the world and I said
hey let me help you with entrepreneurs
and so I helped them with the young
entrepreneurship program and while I was
doing that they gave me a laptop and so
I had a laptop to use and I've done that
constantly throughout my career I
remember when I needed office space I'd
sold my business and I was looking at
you know I'm going to do next and I want
an office to work from I need up
connecting with a venture capital firm
when I joined them to help them build
their business and bring in new leads
and in exchange for my services and
helping them I also got a free office
space and then I started building my
next company through that and I had four
of us working from that office in a
really prestigious location in Toronto
one of the best addresses you can have
and I got that for free because i was
helping them with their business and so
you always have to find creative ways to
get what you want I think too many
people just think of things as black and
white and there's only one way to get to
your desired outcome and it's never the
case it's never just about you sure if
you have the money go out and buy it but
does there are always there are always
other ways to get what you're after you
should be creative you got to think
outside the box you'll be resourceful
and the good news is that's what
entrepreneurs do best so get on it next
up the bond great video as usual thanks
Devon I always find daily motivation on
your channel my question is throughout
the highs and lows of putting out a book
how do you say focus during those low
points what keeps you from compromising
certain things just to get the book out
quicker hashtag BTW a 49 hash tag team
motivation so it's a great question and
i think in my case it was extended right
initially i was supposed to have it in
before the end of the year and now they
want it in january and so i think that's
a couple things that helped me stay
motivated difficult challenging process
and the rewards of it are seeing the
feedback right
you guys enjoying consume went and have
your lives change from it that's what
I'm really excited by but it can be hard
to remember that sometimes when you're
in the the grind here in gloomy Toronto
weather with a big headache having to go
write the book so a couple of things
that helped me one always keeping in
mind the greater vision what I'm trying
to do why I'm doing this what's the
purpose what's my why right I want to
build to help a billion entrepreneurs I
think the book is a having you to help
me get there this is classic because if
this was something I was doing just for
the money i would have given up like
this is too hard this is just too hard
too much work to do to justify right and
i think a lot of entrepreneurs they give
up at that point you doing something
you're starting the business and it just
gets too hard and you quit because you
never really had a strong why because
you're never really passionate about it
and so I'm passionate about helping
entrepreneurs I want to reach a billion
of you and this is one way to get there
and so I keep that in mind number two is
I think it helps to have a schedule I
think it helps to plan things in so once
a week I have a set schedule we're here
i am on my book writing day walking the
whole foods and it's part of just part
of my routine and I find everything
around it and other you know meetings
and tasks and priorities and things that
I have to get done in my company go on
other days so I can free up this time
and so you have to make it important and
you got to schedule it out in your
calendar I prefer a whole day especially
for writing the book because it takes so
long to get into the writing part that I
can't me I don't know maybe you're
different but I can't do it in half an
hour chunks is actually half an hour
just to remember what I was writing
about before before I can get into
actually writing new stuff
and so the early part of my book writing
day is pretty low productivity and then
builds up and so I need to have a huge
chunk of time and I find that for
anything creative I need to have a big
open spot to be able to really work and
so that's what I do my one day a week
this book writing day and then the last
thing I think really helped us having a
having a team I think when with any big
goal if you are only committing to
yourself it's easy to lose sight of the
goal right it's easy to drop it we let
ourselves down constantly but if
somebody else is involved right I'm
fortunate to have so many great people
involved you know Jen and Jay rise
helping me with the book itself and all
the great people that I've interviewed
to be featured and then both of my
agents and the publisher there's a lot
of people counting on me making this
video series right all you guys cannon
on me too I find that having that
external pressure happen to please other
people having to maybe not pleased but
having to get something to other people
committing to them I like following
through my commitments and so I find
that helps too so have a strong why lock
it off in your schedule and commit to
others that helps next Peter I have a
question about a question you answered
you said you don't have to know about
anything but how do i create a product
I've got this idea but I don't know how
to manufacture it I tried it once before
with watches and found the cheapest
manufacturing with charging 200 euros
please help okay so I don't member
saying that you don't have to know about
anything but i'll take you at your word
there if I was starting to business and
I didn't know how to write in fact you
want to start watches I don't know
anything about
couple options one learn everything
there was to know both watches are you
going to be able to be the guy who can
be the technician who can make it who
can be the expert at watches will take
the apprenticeships learn the techniques
Limina processes to build for the
world's greatest watches right and that
applies to any business are you the guy
who can actually create the product and
and build it and market it and be the
person in the business if that's not you
if you don't if you don't know how to
manufacture if you no more importantly
no no interest in learning how to
manufacture it then you need to partner
up I would look at who can i align
myself with already has access to my
target market and find some kind of way
to do a joint venture with them maybe
it's only on your first watch line you
can got ideas for 100 watches and you
partner up on the first one with them
and their manufacturing capabilities and
you're going to go out there and hustle
and market it and you may lose a little
bit of that deal right you give up a
certain percentage but what you gain is
the expertise and you massively reduce
your risk because otherwise like you
said it's 200 euros per watch to create
and you may not have that kind of access
to capital to view them put out and it's
also a massive risk and so I hate risk
at the start I find a way to defer by
partnering up next up Alec hey man you
should do a video on the art of creating
a short but valuable value proposition
Thanks that's interesting that he said
short but valuable because to me short
is valuable I guess in the the the
wording there makes it feel like if you
had more words and it would be more
valuable and that is almost never the
case at least I find I think people have
a DD and they want to get the message
quickly and just using more words won't
help you in terms of creating the value
proposition for me it really depends on
the audience and understanding one what
they're interested in
how you can help them with their pain
points and problems are and then to also
thinking about what it is that you
staying for and having something that
wants that is a magnet that attracts
people to you so as an example you know
you look at my my social media bios all
that says is I hashtag believe in
entrepreneurs and people might see that
and think that's a terrible value
proposition because it doesn't say
exactly what I do it goes against a
tradition of most companies who will say
specifically what they do and I think
this is the evolution of growing a
business is the evolution of marketing
where when you first start selling a
product typically you're talking about
the features right that's how most
people start out just talk about what
you can do and then somewhere along the
lines you learn about the benefits you
learn about selling the benefits you're
not selling the features anymore you
know if you're if you're selling nails
you're not selling a nail anymore you're
selling the whole you're selling the
hole in the wall you're selling the
ability to hang pictures up on the wall
you're selling the benefits and that's
how 99% of the world sells but if you
look at the biggest companies look at
the most successful companies they've
understand that what you need to do is
sell a core value you need to sell a
feeling you need to sell some emotion
and that's what finding your one word is
all about I've talked about a lot on
this channel in these videos you got
one thing that you stand for that really
makes you different that no matter what
product or service you are selling that
would be who you are so for example you
know I believe in entrepreneurs I
believe in people it just says that as a
general rule if you are around me then
you are going to start doing greater
things it's just part of what I am
naturally good at and love and enjoy
doing and I can apply that vest to
entrepreneurs because I actually have
some background experience and be able
to build businesses but if it wasn't an
entrepreneurship I'd find a way to
believe in others I'd help people be
great snowboarders or be great piano
players or build great chairs you know
whatever it is because that's who I am
and that attracts certain people write
that attracted you guys to my channel if
you don't love the believe message
you're not watching these videos anymore
and so I think finding your one word and
articulating that and articulate in a
way that makes sense for your target
audience that's really the secret behind
creating an amazing value proposition
okay next up borrelia hello there i
absolutely love your videos the first
videos i watch when i come on youtube
hey thanks really i really appreciate
that it would be great if you could do a
video or a series of short videos and
how one can work out the preliminary
stages of a business how do you do your
own market research on a particular
business one is pointed to venture into
how to handle the competition out there
and trying to fill your goody bag as
well so a lot of different ways to go my
favorite way to build a business is
around scratching my own itch my market
research is me I make something because
I want to make something because I feel
that it's missing and that's why I go
out and do it and I've talked about it
before in the channel but why did I make
the end special series yeah you talk
about coming to the channel every day
and start your day with the videos you
watch the in spread so why did I make
that series I didn't want to make that
series I'm
because I needed it in my life because I
wanted something that I could go to
every single day and get some motivation
to help me think bigger to think bigger
to think next level to surround myself
with people who may not be in my
environment right now but who are doing
next level kind of stuff right that
pushed me outside my comfort zone that's
what I wanted and that was desperately
searching on YouTube and I didn't find
anything you think about how many how
many videos are uploaded every single
day on YouTube and there was nothing
that solved this need and so I made it
and is taken off and a lot of you guys
watch and suppressed so every day and
sing the wake up every morning song
right and i love it and so my market
research is me if i like it and i use it
and I'm proud of it then I'm going to
share and is a good chance a lot of
people are going to like it as well and
so if you could build around your own
niche build around something that you
love and you want there's a good chance
other people want it as well and then in
terms of handling the competition you
know my view on that is you look at my
channel as an example the release is no
direct competition like the reason for
creating the product that i've created
was because it didn't exist and those
other people have motivational videos
but it wasn't what I was needing in my
life in my business and so are not super
worried about it but if you're creating
a part of the service that does exist
and that there's lots of people else
that are doing it two things that come
to mind one is you have to stand out
again through a value through what
stand for figure out your one word and
put that into all your marketing and
because that's going to be something
that will help attract target customers
to you who believe in the same thing and
ideal customers who will pay more money
and spend a lot more time with you and
refer a lot more customers to you and
then I think about how else can I
differentiate myself because if you are
an average company with an average
product with an average price guess what
you're going to get average results
right mediocre results and probably
worse because you're new because you
have no brand built up where your
competitors have some kind of
credibility already they have a track
record and a history and a name and so
you need to have some way to
differentiate yourself beyond just
having the value in your one word what
else what unique component of your
product or your service can you offer
that it's so different and sometimes
that's just bringing yourself into it so
as an example I love salsa dancing and
say I love photography I could be the
photographer for the salsa dancing world
and i would have a way better chance i'd
be able to send out and get great
clients because i'm part of that
community because i speak the language
because i know what salsa dancers do and
i know what they like in a great picture
right until I would beat out every other
photographer because I'm the guy that
specializes and so I've been looking at
how can you combine your passions to
bring more of yourself too
company and give yourself a better
chance of sending out next stop Fodor
great video I came here not to learn
something anymore even though I always
do but more for energy and motivation
for a day it makes me do amazing things
because I see people around me doing the
same thing thank you for the confluent I
think on that fedora you don't come to
learn stuff but you do so that's good
this speaks to the comment and the video
that I had last week about having an
environment most people have environment
that sucks it's just true you know your
friends in your life aren't doing great
things the Paris in your life haven't
done great things and said that they're
not wonderful and supportive people
which they usually are they just don't
get it they just don't understand the
bigger vision and your desire to want to
do something but nobody has done before
that's the entrepreneur dreamer and so
yeah you need to surround yourself with
people ideas resources and i love that
this channel can be a home for you guys
I love this channel could be a home for
the dreamers the people want to do
something big you know I wish I had this
when I was starting my first company
because I really struggled and I didn't
have people around me that could help
and so I really appreciate that comment
means a lot to me and encourage all of
you to take a really good hard look at
your environment look at your physical
environment look at your office look at
where you're working is it inspiring
this to make you want to do great big
things look at the youtube channels and
media you're consuming look at the
youtube channels wena consuming does it
help you want to be something bigger
right and if not then change it quite
often a lot of the habits that you have
you've just formed and you don't even
realize hold you where you are where you
need to change those if you want to do
something greater alright last question
Kira Evan thank you so much for what you
do I've been feeling a little
overwhelmed that I've started something
of the adds to my book it's a children
book and listening to you always brings
me my energy level up I know you do a
lot but you make it look easy just want
to say thanks well thank you for that
comment here I really appreciate it I do
a lot I don't know that I make it look
easy that's certainly not my intention I
don't want to get people's hopes up and
say that this is an easy thing anybody
can do it I think it requires a lot of
hard work you know i'm making this video
even though i feel like crap the weather
sucks I'm out of breath I'm tired it's
easy for me to just stay home stay in
bed I think if I was an employee the
company anybody would have would be able
to understand that I'm not feeling well
today and just let me cash it in for the
day and I think I think that's life was
an entrepreneur I think that's the life
of someone who wants to build something
special who wants to build something
beyond themselves like it's a insane
amount of hard work and I'm super happy
that I'm able to motivate you and that
the videos are a source of inspiration
for you but I hope I don't make it just
look easy because man it's an insane
amount of work and it doesn't always
feel like work because I'm doing
something I love and you should too what
it's a grind
and I love it and I wouldn't want it any
other way really but it certainly is not
easy so thank you guys for watching I
got a breath my arm is tired I'm excited
to go over my book though and I love all
the feedback and questions so I'd love
to know what you guys think of this
video back to the question will hiring
the wrong people let me know your
thoughts in the comments and if you have
a question about my book or your book or
the book writing process leave it in the
comments below and I'll do my best to
answer in next week's video thank you
guys for watching get you need to
believe and i'll see you soon